if you put people in the scanner and
tell them to just do nothing just rest
in the scanner don't do anything at all
it turns out that there's a region in
the midline of the cerebral cortex
that's known as the default mode network
that just lights up that just all of a
sudden gets very very active I mean what
you're in told to do nothing and then
your brain starts to use up energy a lot
a lot of ATP in this you know activation
in the medial frontal areas and that's
called the default mode network because
when you're told it nothing you default
to activity in this mode and when you
inquire what's going on there a lot of
it has to do with my wandering and just
daydreaming and a lot of that has to do
with the self referencing our favorite
subject which is me of course so we
generate narratives I wonder how long
I'm going to be in the scanner and I'm
feeling a little bit contracted and you
know because it's claustrophobic and
these magnets are banging like crazy or
whatever it is you're thinking in terms
of your you past present and future and
you're developing narratives where I'm
going to go to lunch when this is over
or whatever it is and those narratives
are a form of self reference and that's
called as I said I mean it's called also
called the narrative mode Network or the
narrative network and it's the story of
me when you train people in MBSR you
find that another area of the cortex
lights up more lateral after eight weeks
of training and mindfulness and that
that area is associated with a region
called the insula and that doesn't have
a linear time based narrative it's just
the experiencing of the present moment
in the body breathing in breathing out
awake no narrative no agenda and the
interesting thing and this is the study
when they when they put people through
eight weeks of MBSR this narrative
network
decreases in activity and this
experiential network increases in
activity and they become uncoupled so
they're no longer caught together in
such a way so this one can actually
attenuate and liberate you a little bit
from the constant thinking thinking
thinking a lot of which is driven of
course by anxiety and what's wrong with
me story of me is often a depressing
story and a fear-based story
we're like driving the car with the
brake on with the emergency brake on and
if we learn how to just kind of release
it everything will unfold
with less strain with less stress and
with a greater sense of life unfolding
rather than you're driving through it to
get to some great pot of gold at the end
or it might just be your grave